what is happening reject nation it's
Greg al Bakir all hiring zag nation it's
John Humphrey over here you're tearing
me apart be some more my jacket and
everything we're excited for this so
this video is going to be dedicated to
Diego Shai guest today because the
English is part of the personal patrons
whatever video you request we will
definitely do and this was his video
request the AYGO shy Dez hey good
thinking mad me early birthday after the
present you pledged for congratulations
so we're going to check up a trailer for
the disaster our debt is s or artists
based on the best-selling book and the
account of the making of the filled the
room room what John's favorite like
family films favorite family movie hey
go kid you go to watch out with your dad
no you me and my dad my sister goes
sometimes midnight screenings my mom
came one you know this is something my
dad found years ago brought home to the
family we watched it we all thought it
was hilarious my mom thought it was a
little repulsive at times and then it's
become sort of a beloved you know yeah
one of our beloved movie yeah yeah I
watched Cheryl girls with my dad when I
was a boy oh good let's get to it is any
action what line what in line oh no
hitter it's not true yeah [ __ ] I did
not hit her I did not
oh hi Lord what is behind take 13 action
I did not hit right okay okay
why
oh I didn't I did it not grew it won't
sit
oh thank 67 Wow
hi here no he's a wise old gray man
we'll get there action action action I
just came in here they acted like an
arrow okay action
I did not hit her it's not truly
[ __ ] I did not hit her I did not oh
hi mark
[Applause]
oh man well John what do you think you
know what man I thought this was a cool
way to go with this trailer I like they
just went with the scene and as a room
fan myself I'm definitely excited to see
this bass on this and then the first
thing I got Oh addresses is James Franco
you know because it's a huge tall order
for him to play but he seems like he's
bringing a full performance to this yeah
I think so too I mean I feel like James
Franco could have easily just done the
Tommy Wiseau impression from the room
but he seems to be doing who Tommy
Wiseau was off-camera in a real
naturalistic way when I feel like it
might have been easier just to do an
impersonation of what he was being like
in the room and it serves that scene
they showed us you know it's like it has
the one moment we all know but it has
all the context around it yeah yeah and
it has the classic kind of banter you'd
expect when you see Seth Rogen in the
same room with James Franco yeah I'm
excited that game for Dave Franco's in
this movie too under his brothers
direction because the Franco I feel it's
really establishes own he's a hilarious
guy seeing the brothers being a movie
star in a movie together seems like a
fantastic time yeah it's like a dave
Franco part done and I was like oh it's
dave Franco not it's James Franco's
brother yeah I thought of it as a
different guy and yeah seeing Seth Rogen
was a nice surprise seeing all the
different comedians who pop up in this
trailer was a nice surprise and for a
film that's a cult hit like the room I
feel like it would be fascinating to see
a behind the scenes film look at how
this all went down so
especially after all the disputes and
all the different accounts of how it
came together and ultimately culminating
in Gregg's esteros book this is pretty
fascinating I gotta mention yeah
especially to see it play out in a movie
by these these guys well guys are you
excited for the disaster artist why
don't you go ahead and leave a comment
below are you afraid of becoming a Tommy
Wiseau if your inspiring filmmaker who
is sure I agree with everybody should
subscribe to the real reject click that
notification bell he is dat John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram and
you can check out all our exclusive
perks and rewards over at patreon.com
slash the real rejects a lot of fun
stuff over there Diego shy Dez happy you
requested this and a few other people
did but Diego shy Dez but Diego gets
demented credit